this video is sponsored by brilliant the
first 200 to use the link in the
description get 20% off the annual
subscription anyone who's ever been to
in and out knows to expect no matter
where you are the same consistent burger
smiling cashier and long lines residents
of Portland Oregon were known to drive
four hours each way to the nearest
restaurant in Grants Pass and before
there were any in Phoenix locals
supposedly flew to Ontario California
had lunch and promptly flew back and yet
despite seemingly unlimited demand in
and out is one of the smallest major
fast-food chains in the world with only
347 locations
there are over twice as many water
burgers almost four times as many Five
Guys and 40 times as many McDonald's
just in the US since it began in 1948
it's only opened an average of five
restaurants a year to less than subway
opened in a single day at its peak in
other words in and out deliberately
leaves money on the table refusing to
expand even where huge profits are
guaranteed why profitable high margin
industries are often kind of boring how
do you make money selling toothbrushes
uh well you sell them plastic handles
with bristles on the end as it turns out
don't cost very much to make and
therefore have healthy margins someone
of course will try to turn them into a
subscription make them out of aluminum
ooh and call it the youth brush but most
of us don't have a passion for consumer
dental products so the business model is
simple you hand me a couple of dollars
I'll give you a rod with some bristles
things get interesting when companies
have to get creative when competition is
high or consumer willingness to spend
money low they have to find some other
way to make a profit for restaurants
it's all about selling drinks with
printers the money's really in the ink
and Costco's low prices those are offset
by annual membership fees selling
millions of french fries for a few cents
each isn't a bad business for McDonald's
but it's found something even better
real estate while the company only owned
and operates 15% of its restaurants and
the rest are franchised it owns almost
all of their buildings and the land
beneath them franchisees pay about eight
to fifteen percent of their revenue as
rent to McDonald's who makes money
whether they're profitable or not and
that's on top of the normal franchise
royalty after going on a huge shopping
spree during the 2008 recession
McDonald's now owns more than thirty
billion dollars worth of real estate
not only is its business diversified but
much of that income is tax-deductible
in other words McDonald's is actually
more real estate investor than fast food
franchise likewise if you think of
in-and-out only as a burger chain it
doesn't make much sense why not open
more locations why not change and
perfect the recipes or add new menu
items but if in-and-out is really about
serving a predictable familiar
experience more than the food itself
opening new locations and trying new
things are huge risks in an out secret
ingredient the thing it's really selling
is consistency
nearly every location has the same
familiar layout drive-through lane and
iconic crossed palm trees a reference to
the founders favorite movie unlike other
fast-food restaurants the interior is
clean well-lit and easy on the eyes most
importantly the menu is dead simple
hamburger cheeseburger french fries
three flavors of shakes and the two
hamburger patty two slices of cheese
double-double that's it to drink there's
milk hot cocoa coffee classic and diet
coke root beer Dr Pepper 7up lemonade
and iced tea even with a few secret
variations like grilled cheese animal
fries and the Neapolitan milkshake
there's nowhere near the selection of
say a Dairy Queen or McDonald's which
have about twice as many drinks alone as
everything at in-and-out
its menu changes not seasonally or
annually but maybe once a generation in
1958 bottled sodas became fountain
drinks milkshakes were added in 75 dr.
pepper 21 years later lemonade in 2003
and hot chocolate 15
years after that when a fourth beverage
size was proposed a fight reportedly
broke out inside the company and in 2018
it closed all 37 locations in Texas for
a full 48 hours when it found buns that
didn't meet its quality standards the
downside of this consistency is that it
can't respond to changes in the industry
in 2015
McDonald's was able to turn around
declining sales with its all-day
breakfast and caught off guard by
Chipotle's success many chains have
tried capturing that market by
introducing more healthy alternatives on
the other hand by keeping things simple
in and out can carefully optimize every
ingredient in its business formula
inevitably new items mean longer lines
confused employees and added complexity
the mick cafe coffee for example
required each store to buy a fifteen to
twenty thousand dollar espresso machine
and train employees on how to use it at
in and out there are five levels of
employees level one the janitor and
counter handouts two for the drive
through three and four who make french
fries five who's allowed to assemble
burgers and six the only person
authorized to man the grill which
requires at least three to six months of
training not only does this ensure
well-trained cooks but it also turns
fast-food into a proper well-paid
profession level one employees are
generally paid more than minimum wage
and managers make an average of one
hundred and sixty thousand dollars a
year with some making well over a
quarter of a million dollars overseeing
a single location it's not hard to see
why they stay with the company for an
average of 14 years almost all current
and ex in-and-out employees say the same
thing it's a stressful chaotic and yet
highly desirable job everyone
full and part-time receives 401k plans
dental and vision coverage and paid
vacation days even more impressive it
does all that despite having some of the
lowest prices in the industry a
hamburger fries and milkshake costs just
six dollars and eighty-five cents about
half the price of the same order at
Shake Shack any other company would
without hesitation
sport this formula of high skilled
employees a simple menu and consistent
quality across the country and then when
that worked across the globe the fact
that it hasn't is more than anything
else a reflection of its values set 70
years ago in Baldwin Park California by
husband-and-wife founders Esther and
Harry Snyder it was the first place ever
to use a two-way speaker system allowing
drivers to place orders while in line
they would eventually open 18 more
locations but strictly only when they
could afford to buy the property
outright never on a loan principled
thoughtful founders like the Snyder's
aren't all that hard to find but rarely
does the second generation inherit those
same values only about a third of family
businesses survive the second generation
and another of 50 percent don't last
until the third in and out is one of the
few chains that has stayed true to its
beginnings despite going through several
traumatic changes when Harry died in
1967 his son rich took over who then
died in a plane crash in 93 after which
his brother guy replaced him only to die
six years later Esther then returned to
manage the company finally in the
riskiest move of all after she died in
2006 presidency was given to someone
outside the family Mark Taylor until
guy's daughter Lindsay reached the age
of 30 when she inherited 50% of the
business and then almost full control in
2007 at age 35 in and out has seen six
different leaders been heavily pressured
by outsiders to franchise the business
and watch the industry it helped create
change dramatically and yet today 70
years later any of its very first
customers would feel right at home in
any of its 300 locations its current
president is the highest rated female
CEO in the US by employees and while the
company continues growing entering Texas
in 2011 Oregon in 2015 and soon Colorado
it does so very carefully Lindsay still
in her 30s doesn't expect to expand east
of Texas in her lifetime and never in
every US state with so few locations
every grand opening is a major event
with free organic marketing and
much fanfare lines are so long that the
company hires off-duty police officers
to manage traffic and flies in all-star
employees experienced workers who
managed the chaos and long ten hour
shifts the biggest bottleneck is
distribution buns are baked daily
milkshakes 100% dairy and there are no
freezers or microwaves that means
ingredients have to be prepared at
distribution centers currently in
Baldwin Park Lathrop California Dallas
Phoenix Draper Utah and Colorado Springs
from there they need to be delivered
within a single day's Drive to each of
their stores which limits new locations
to roughly 500 mile radius from each
distribution center whether you're a fan
of Shake Shack Whataburger Five Guys or
McDonald's you have to admit there's
something special about in and out while
McDonald's will always make more money
serve more customers and be more widely
known in and out has arguably done
something even harder keep a legacy
alive while staying true to its original
ideals over 70 years and through six
generations of leadership the lesson is
whether in business life or learning the
hardest part is often just keeping a
good thing going enrolling in a class is
easy but remembering to actually go and
retaining the knowledge much harder and
that's exactly how brilliant is designed
to help you
brilliant teaches you math science and
computer science with engaging pictures
and puzzles then helps you check your
actual understanding in other words you
don't just memorize formulas you
actually see how and why something works
with daily challenges you can solve
quick problems even on the go with their
mobile app they're adding new courses
all the time on computer science
differential equations scientific
thinking and geometry fundamentals for
example you can use the link in the
description to start learning for free
and the first 200 people will get 20%
off the annual premium subscription so
you can view all the daily challenges
and unlock dozens of problem-solving
courses thanks to brilliant em to you
for watching this video
you